[MUSIC PLAYING]
Are you interested in
making your app smarter?
Understanding your
user's location
is one of the key
ingredients that can help
unlock a simpler and more
intuitive user experience.
I'm James McGill, and
I'm going to show you
how you can use the Google
Places API for Android
to intelligently adapt
your app's behavior based
on the user's current location.
For some time,
developers have been
able to use the Location
Services on Android
to better understand
where their users are.
However, our users
and these APIs
have been talking in
two different languages.
Location APIs communicate
using latitude and longitude.
But when you and I talk
about where to meet,
we use the name of a particular
cafe or restaurant, not
long numbers.
The Google Places
API for Android
provides the missing key needed
to translate between these two
languages and powered by
Google's database of over 100
million places.
So that you can
turn this into this.
Let's imagine that we're
building an application
to improve our users' well-being
by providing fitness tips no
matter where they are.
When a user opens
the app, we want
to show the information
that is most useful to them
at that time, and at
that particular place.
We could ask them
where they are,
but who needs
another tap getting
in the way of using our app?
Using the Google Places API
Get Current Place method
we can skip that prompt,
and automatically
determine which
place the user is at.
Get Current Place
returns a list of places
based on the device's
current location
and ordered by likelihood.
While similar functionality
has been available via the Web
Places API for some time,
we have significantly
improved both
accuracy and precision
in bringing the API to Android.
We've achieved this by
deeply integrating the API
with the wide variety
of sensors available
on a modern mobile device,
including Wi-Fi and Bluetooth.
By combining the
list of likely places
with context from the app, we
can improve these estimates
even further.
In our case, we can use
the place type associated
with each entry to filter
down to only fitness venues,
like parks and gyms.
Along with each place, they
Get Current Place method also
returns a likelihood.
That's a value
between zero and one
representing how likely
it is that the device is
at a particular place.
We can use this value as
a threshold in our app
to ensure that we only infer
the location when it really
makes sense.
For our fitness app, a
likelihood of more than 0.7
for a place that is identified
as being either a gym or a park
is a very strong
signal, which we
can use to avoid having to
ask the user where they are.
Awesome.
The Google APIs team is invested
in improving the accuracy
of these place detection APIs.
So over time, you
should expect to see
the likelihood of the first
place returned increase.
If you want to help
us get there faster,
you can by calling the
Report Device at Place method
in cases where you
have a strong signal
that the user is at a
particular location.
Once submitted, this data is
used anonymously to improve
our model of the world,
but cannot be retrieved
by your application
or end users.
So if it's important to
have access to this data,
you should also store in
a persistent data store.
The best part is that
this functionality
is available for
free up to a default
limit of 150,000 queries per
day for verified developers.
Need more?
No worries.
Get in touch with
us at this URL,
or check out this
site for instructions
on how to verify your
development project.
With the Google
Places API, you can
bring the intelligence of
semantic location to your app.
To get started, check
out the Getting Started
Guide at this URL.
I'm James McGill,
and I can't wait
to see you going places with the
Google Places API for Android.
[MUSIC PLAYING]